eine dieser prächtigen oasen im grauen
loch im herzen bangkoks
der tempel city war an
frau und seiner buddhistischen brüder
nehmen ihr jeden morgen eine verwandlung
vor die kutte im leuchtenden orange muss
weichen wird in plastik verhüllt aus dem
tempel wird ein testzentrum aus münchen
werden wir die ziener freiwillige im
kampf gegen coop
wir müssen schutzkleidung anlegen
sonst können wir uns nicht um die leute
kümmern vor allem nasen augen mund
müssen geschützt werden das ist das
wichtigste das ist jetzt unsere mission
jeden tag hier im tempel bieten wir
kostenlose corona tests an für jeden der
zu uns kommt
es kommen viele in sorge um ihre
gesundheit die infektionen greifen um
sich ungewissheit quält
auch an ist heute hier hin und
hergerissen von gefühlen dankbar für die
hilfe der mönche und sauer auf die
regierung
es ist furchtbar
die regierung ist völlig nutzlos
überfordert wenn uns die männchen nicht
helfen würden hilft uns keiner
tausende haben dass wir schon über sich
ergehen lassen dass der tempel
neuerdings diese andere form der
erkenntnis bietet hat sich
herumgesprochen
es gibt viele menschen die nicht genug
geld für einen test haben wir nehmen
unser geld und sammeln spenden und
kaufen davon schnelltest positiv ist den
versuchen wir hier im tempel zu
versorgen oder im krankenhaus
unterzubringen man wartet wenige minuten
eine ewigkeit ihr ergebnis ist negativ
aber die erleichterung währt nur kurz
ich habe angst wenn sich jemand in
meiner familie infiziert was sollen wir
tun wir haben keine verbindungen kein
geld viele versuchen schon gar nicht
mehr einen krankenhaus platz zu bekommen
sie sterben einsam zu hause
überleben eine kostenfrage doch auch der
tod ist nicht umsonst für eine
bestattung fehlt vielen das geld wieder
helfen freiwillige bringen die leichen
ins krematorium des tempels der tod hat
konjunktur in thailand das überfordert
den start und fordert die mitmenschen
das sind alles spenden die leute wollen
helfen die leute aus der mittelschicht
und aus der oberklasse spenden viel sie
geben uns geld wir kaufen davon alles
nötige sauerstoff alles
hilfe für die lebenden und die toten
für teils ist das normal wir tun immer
was wir können wir leben in einem
buddhistischen land wir teilen wir
helfen uns wir sehen nicht zu wenn wir
auf die regierung warten würden wäre
alles zu spät
thailands mächtige der monarch das
militär die regierung sind getriebene
der krise ihre bilanz ist nicht gut das
gesundheitssystem am anschlag tausende
infektionen hunderte tote tag für tag
vakzine fehlen kann er zwölf prozent
details sind doppelt geimpft dazu der
lockdown die wirtschaftliche not frust
wut verzweiflung wächst und treibt
menschen auf die straße
die regierung versagt anders kann man
das nicht nennen
wenn die freiwilligen nicht helfen
würden wären die straßen voller leichen
tote über all die leute hätten nichts
keine medizin keine hilfe nichts
[Musik]
die pandemie fordert allen alles ab das
droht die gesellschaft zu spalten und
schweißt sie doch auch zusammen
ach wir verbrauchen das hier alles so
schnell hier vorne liegt säckeweise reis
alles gespendet das geht schnell weg und
das sind pakete mit dem nötigsten für
die häusliche quarantäne da drin sind
masken ein sauerstoff messgerät
thermometer ein paar medikamente
paracetamol
ein volles lager kann schnell leer
werden denn der bedarf ist groß auf die
logistik kommt es an in eigenleistung
haben helfer dafür eine app entwickelt
jeder punkt ein problem bei rot ist die
not am größten es gibt viele rote punkte
in bangkok
wir hoffen dass sich herumspricht was
wir tun die leute sollen wissen dass ist
freiwillig das ist nicht unsere pflicht
oder so
eigentlich müsste der staat das system
das leisten aber der lässt die leute im
stich wir wollen den behörden zeigen wie
man helfen kann unkompliziert schnell
tempo zählt aber davon bleibt ruhig
stress hilft nicht hat ihn noch nie
geholfen er hat dem staat mal als soldat
gedient jetzt ist der freiwilliger
sanitäter unterwegs um leben zu retten
die sauerstoffsättigung der patientin
soll niedrig seien das müssen wir als
erstes überprüfen die frau ist schwach
in solchen fällen kann sich die
situation schnell verschlimmern es kann
komplikationen geben ich hoffe wir
können rechtzeitig helfen
für einen arzt fehle ihr das geld
erzählt die frau im krankenhaus sei kein
platz und impfstoff den gebe es doch
nicht für arme leute wie sie dankbar
sagt sie den helfern dass sie ihr nun
wieder etwas hoffnung machen
klar ich sorge mich auch um meine
gesundheit aber wer kümmert sich sonst
um diejenigen die schon infiziert sind
wer spricht mit ihm menschen verhungern
weil ihn niemand mehr was zu essen
bringt wenn ich zu viel angst habe wer
hilft ihnen dann
die fragen quälen vielleicht ganz gut
dass nicht viel zeit zum nachdenken
bleibt da draußen sind zu viele die
hilfe brauchen jetzt